pas si un quartier bourgeois et
résidentiels situés à deux pas de la
tour eiffel c'est ici que sont
rassemblés une centaine de manifestants
kurdes tous sont venus protester devant
l'ambassade de turquie un pays qui
compte entre 15 et 18 millions de kurdes
dans la foule ismaël un réfugié
politique
il a fuit la turquie après le coup
d'état militaire de 1980 c'est à cette
date que les kurdes en quête
d'indépendance commence à être perçue
comme une menace à l'intégrité du pays
à 58 ans ismaël et le président du
centre culturel kurde de paris et
demeure un militant actif
vivait dans notre région avec et de
façon autonome une façon qu'on peut
vivre avec notre identité notre culture
avec noter votre histoire on veut vivre
vraiment comme un coeur de
almas trendy qu elle aussi réfugié
politique
c'est en 2003 que cet activiste de la
cause kurde eux rejoint paris après des
années de persécution qu'alexis à la
charte d'accueil des chicanes jaden et
will iam en larmes après
celui là près de
shanghai ont présenté les jazzeux trash
de cheval
le kurdistan une région à cheval sur
quatre pays l'iran l'irak la syrie et la
turquie la turquie concentre à elle
seule la moitié des 38 millions de
kurdes pour conserver leur identité les
kurdes de turquie ont dû s'opposer à un
état centralisateur et répressif et
c'est en 1978 et crée le pkk le parti
des travailleurs kurdes une mouvance
armée considérée par de nombreux pays
comme une organisation terroriste le pkk
lutte depuis 1984 pour obtenir un
territoire autonome dans le sud-est de
la turquie
[Musique]
retour à paris dans le cortège les
slogans fusent et les drapeaux de
abdullah au challenge flotte
celui que les kurdes comparée à nelson
mandela est devenu le martyr de la cause
dit à pop art est chaud c'est le leader
kurde le leader du pkk c'est lui entre
guillemets tu nous a ouvert la route
abdullah ocalan a été arrêté en 1999
puis condamné à mort une peine commuée
en prison à vie en 2002
[Musique]
la communauté kurde est souvent érigée
en exemple de cohésion et de solidarité
pour comprendre pourquoi il faut se
rendre dans le quartier du faubourg
saint denis le fief historique
c'est ici entre les boulevard sébastopol
et magenta que les premiers kurdes se
sont installés il ya 30 ans monsieur
ismaël koné le coin comme sa poche
voilà un sandwich se passe elle était au
coeur de
la vallée delvar le seul à battre ici
les commerces kurdes sont tous mitoyen
direction le salon de coiffure monsieur
ismaël il retrouve le patron un ami
haut rhin est venu s'installer en france
il y a quelques années le lieu idéal
pour monter un business
nous avons
un peu plus loin rue d'enghien des
affiches effrayante fleurissent sur les
murs
[Musique]
c'est la communauté kurde en france à
paris qu'ils font cette affiche là on
fait des affiches pour souvenir pour
rappel ce schéma sec en route vers le
centre culturel monsieur ismaël tient
absolument à nous montrer les livres et
cd kurdes en vente dans le salon de thé
une revanche sur un passé récent j'avais
pas les droits d écouter la musique
écrire de c'était interdit c'est une
raison de être coupable à léo prison
mais ça ici aux enfants en france là on
vive avec notre culture librement la
culture kurde sous tendu par la langue
kurde donne à ce peuple un vif sentiment
d'identité
direction evry en proche banlieue alma
sts la jeune femme rencontrée dans la
manifestation nous a donné rendez vous
au centre culturel de mésopotamie c'est
ici que cette ancienne chanteuse donne
des cours de kurdes aux enfants de la
diaspora
les moines et majoral à témara prada kg
bourgi
en turquie l'article 42 de la
constitution interdit toujours
l'enseignement de toute autre langue que
le turc obligeante ainsi tout un peuple
à renoncer aux piliers fondateurs de son
identité
[Musique]
devenus les symboles de leur
nationalisme la langue et l'hymne kurdes
sont enseignés ici en france loin de
leur terre natale
j'ai beaucoup chanté et
dans les chansons et j'arrive à le
rendre compte au lit
[Musique]
ninon
morichon et la tête mais marino et
gaiman mois lesquels elle baissait mais
cette crise mais ça va car oui j 13 n -b
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez les kurdes de paris l'activisme
politique est une vocation
retour au centre culturel aujourd'hui
une cinquantaine de militants sont
réunis pour préparer les prochaines
élections législatives turques depuis
1994 certaines formations politiques
kurdes sont représentés au parlement
turc
murat tu es l'un des 250 mille kurdes de
france il est arrivé à paris à l'âge de
7 ans pour rejoindre son père réfugié
politique comme pour la plupart de ses
frères de lutte la politique il est
tombé dedans à la naissance de parents
leur a toujours appris que que head
kurdes s'étaient des citoyens de seconde
zone qui écarte s'était il faut rien
demandé au gouvernement et de kurt cité
accepter la souffrance est donc c'était
accepter qu'on n'est pas tous les droits
en france par exemple on peut faire
librement nos activités donner des cours
des activités politiques des activités
culturelles et plus haut qu'on commence
à réfléchir sur nos propres territoires
on peut pas appliquer ces droits là ça
nous paraît encore plus aberrant et au
contraire sont des noms encore plus
faite
de courage à dire voilà il faut que je
mène ce combat un combat bien engagée le
soutien politique et surtout financier
de la diaspora kurde de france leur
permettra peut-être de gagner quelques
sièges au parlement et par là même de
faire entendre davantage la voie kurde
en turquie
privées d'état les cures de mettre en
avant une nation afin d'exister une
nation c'est une culture et une langue
commune mais aussi des traditions cette
année c'est dans l'est parisien a
montreuil que la communauté a tenu à
organiser son nouvel an qui tient aussi
lieu de fête nationale le nez rose à
l'intérieur c'est l'affluence 3500
personnes ont répondu présent
[Musique]
au milieu de la foule on retrouve mur at
c'est lui entre autres qui est à
l'origine de l'organisation d'une et
rose à paris un événement devenu
l'expression même du combat kurde je me
rappelle des années 90 ou carrément on
décrète un couvre-feu et il est interdit
de sortir ce jour là bien sûr le peuple
coeur ne restent pas poitras la mesure
sur la qui sortait mais par contre ils
étaient obligés d'affronter les chars de
l'armée turque medellin avant la faire
signer vision mon sens la
vision se vident nos visions
la projection c'est celle d'un et rose
au pays chaque année plus d'un million
de personnes se regroupent à diyarbakir
la capitale du kurdistan turc
[Musique]
en 2011 en turquie la question kurde
continue d'être un obstacle majeur à
l'harmonie nationale souhaité par ankara
mais à écouter murat telekurs de paris
la reconnaissance tant espérée se
rapproche de jour en jour